ecuador cambia el color amarillo ante
una reducción de casos a nivel nacional
según cifras oficiales
179 de 221 cantores cambian al color
amarillo y se modifican las
restricciones sanitarias y con ello
retornan los estudiantes a las aulas de
clases pero con algunas particularidades
serán los padres de familia quienes
decidirán si llevarán o no a sus hijos a
los centros educativos en los casos de
las escuelas donde asistan todos los
grados en las ciudades en color verde y
amarillo podrán asistir de manera
presencial mientras que en las ciudades
que permanezcan en el semáforo rojo la
asistencia no será obligatoria y poder
ser voluntaria se debe dividir en los
estudiantes por grupos y horarios el
cierre o apertura a las escuelas genera
polémica en el país organizaciones
sociales y padres demandan la reapertura
de las escuelas a causa del abandono
escolar el abuso infantil el embarazo de
adolescentes el suicidio infantil la
desnutrición u otros temas que se han
agudizado a causa de la pandemia
mientras que en otros casos todavía
existe temor de algunos padres de
familia por los aforos que se realizan
en las clases ecuador busca retornar
progresivamente y priorizar la
asistencia presencial a las escuelas en
ciudades como en guayaquil epicentro de
la pandemia en este país es tan densa de
claro que no permitirá el regreso a las
clases ante el incremento del caso de
kobe 19 en esta entidad donde la
atención se ha enfocado en el contagio
de los niños según la autoridad
municipal en guayaquil los riesgos de
contagio se multiplican por 4 ante la
variante micro en la entidad se
registran 18 fallecimientos de adultos
por día y el año lectivo concluirá de
manera virtual serán sancionados las
escuelas que deciden acogerse a la
normativa del ejecutivo nacional